turning to national news tonight capitol  police arrested a virginia man on friday  for allegedly trying to illegally enter  through washington d.c  checkpoint ahead of president-elect joe  biden's inauguration  court documents say wesley allen biehler  was armed with a gun  ammunition and fake credentials the  documents also state that buehler told  the officers he had a handgun  under his car's armrest they searched  his car and found a handgun loaded along  with more than  500 rounds of ammunition in the vehicle  mehler now faces multiple charges  including possession of an unregistered  firearm and possession of unregistered  ammunition